At this point, you've done
a lot with individual inputs.
You should be proud.
>> Right, you've tried out
different input types and
you know how to pick the right one for
the right situation.
>> You've attached useful labels
to your inputs ensuring that users
always know what they are typing
while they are typing.
>> You've used the autocomplete
attribute to help the browser
autofill common input fields.
>> You've used different validation
attributes to validate users' input,
even before they submit your forms.
>> And you've played with
the constraints validation API, for
those times when you need to
validate more complex inputs.
>> In the next lesson, Ken and
I will help you to take a step
back from looking at single inputs
to looking at the forms as a whole.
>> Right.
Let's get started.